bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ce si la grèce alors eh bien je
devrais dans une nouvelle semaine qui
commence donc on est lundi 15 mars
et je commence enfin à écrire jusque là
dans ma thèse j'étais vraiment plus d'un
de la lecture et puis des espèces de
bribes d'écriture un peu mais là je fais
une pause après avoir écrit deux pages
d'une traite ou vous
évidemment elles soient parfaites 1 mais
voilà au moins ses sorties pour un
article universitaire qui serait mon
premier article qui est donc un article
en anglais
et voilà c'est juste besoin de me dire
que enfin tout s'est mis en place dans
ma tête que c'est beaucoup plus clair et
c est au point que j'arrive à à rédiger
quoi donc voilà ça c'est le côté cool et
du coup je vais attaquer la rédaction et
je vais également devoir organiser mon
premier départ sur le terrain en tant
que doctorante puisque jusque là j'ai
fait du terrain donc master hante et
vous voilà avec le co vide et cetera je
me précipitais pas on va dire pour aller
sur le terrain parce que bon je voulais
pas trop même si je sais que si on met
terrain on va dire qu'ils ont d'autres
problèmes que locaux vides
bref voilà je ne voulais pas trop non
plus y aller tant qu'on n'était pas un
peu mieux en turquie au niveau de
l'épidémie
là avec le vaccin avec les restrictions
qui ça j'ai un petit peu au niveau des
couvre feux et cetera
je me dis que c'est peut-être le bon
moment tout temps évidemment respectant
bien les gestes barrière mais voilà je
vais faire ça sachant qu'en plus il faut
que je collecte des données pour
compléter ce que j'ai pour mon article
donc voilà j'espère que ce journal de
test sera celui de mon premier départ
sur le terrain voilà donc à part ça des
lectures de l'écriture peut être un
terrain à venir et puis toujours des
événements universitaire en ligne donc
des séminaires etc
voilà mais tout se passe super bien
[Musique]
on
bon mais on est le matin mais du coup là
je m'apprête à me mettre à bosser
aujourd'hui je bosse depuis la maison je
dois finir un dossier pour une demande
de financement
je dois avancer dans certaines lectures
et des recherches biographiques
je dois aussi et ça c'est super cool
continuer à organiser mon départ sur le
terrain je me suis fixé une date qui est
lundi prochain pour partir dans faut que
j'achète mes billets pour aller jusque
là bas et aprilia toute la question du
logement et comme je travaille dans des
zones rurales
enfin on va dire des petites villes qui
sont dominés par l'accueil la production
agricole au niveau de l'économie
c'est vrai que ce ne sont pas forcément
des lieux qui sont habitués à recevoir
des touristes ou des visiteurs
donc voilà il faut que je réfléchisse un
peu en terme de budget aussi jusque là
j'ai pas un budget extensible quoi donc
le mieux je sais que ce serait de louer
nos voitures sur place pour pouvoir être
totalement indépendante et me déplacer
un peu comme je veux mais dans les faits
je pense que c'est trop cher donc voila
ce genre de détails
j'aime bien voir votre qu'un scooter
vous allez voir enfin bref du coup voilà
je suis en train de s'organiser en tout
cas la grosse partie parce que ce que
j'aime faire aussi c'est me dire que sur
place tant que j'ai un logement c'est le
plus important est que je me
débrouillerai mais bon enfin bref j'ai
trop trop trop trop hâte de partir sur
le terrain c'est en fait j'ai pas
réalisé à quel point c'est passé vite
mais mes dernières données elles datent
de mars avril 2018
donc ça fait vraiment la pile trois ans
que je n'ai pas été sur mon terrain et
que j'ai collecté mes dernières données
ça va un peu ferme choc quand j'ai
réalisé que ça c'est trois ans
parce que j'utilise toujours certains de
mes données dans des travaux et et voilà
elles ont besoin d'être actualisées pour
sûr parce que je dis trois ans mais en
fait j'ai je suis retourné sur le
terrain pour entretenir un peu les les
contacts voir comment ça se passe mais
j'avais pas fais d'entretien à ce moment
là donc là le but ça de cette session
sur le terrain normalement ça va être
d'accès mais questionnaire sur un aspect
précis de ma recherche et dans l'idéal
j'aimerais bien faire une quinzaine
d'entretiens ce serait top
voilà à voir aussi la réalité meet my
space show du coup un autre travail que
je vais devoir accomplir c'est de
rédiger mes questionnaire qui ont
évidemment beaucoup évolué depuis mais
questionnaire de 2018
donc voilà il va falloir que
j'y réfléchisse que je les écris dans un
tuyau que convenable bref donc voilà
pourquoi mon programme des jours à venir
ça reste assez chargé mais c'est quoi
c'est dû charger positif
[Musique]
il
on
[Musique]
hello et bien je vous reprends que
maintenant parce que c'est un peu speed
jusqu'à maintenant donc je suis arrivé à
izmir qui est la plus grosse ville à
proximité de mon terrain donc je
travaille dans des zones on va dire
relativement rural et ils se mirent donc
est la plus grosse ville c'est une des
grandes villes de turquie et se trouve
que c'est pas loin de mon terrain et
voit là forcément on ces temps de
pandémie a beaucoup d'hôtels et de
petites pensions comme on dit ici qui
ont fermé j'ai décidé dans un premier
temps de venir pour deux nuits à izmir
voilà le temps de mettre dans l'ambiance
de travail de terrain parce que ma une
fois que je serai sur place ça va aller
assez vite
voilà dans des cantons très dans des
zones restreintes on va dire que la
nouvelle circule vite qu'on à arriver et
donc je veux être prêtre quand j'arrive
faut pas être prise au dépourvu et tout
ça donc le but ici c'est de commencer à
récolter des infos de me mettre dans
l'ambiance de revoir une dernière fois
mais questionnaire pour que jean soit
satisfaite donc lâché arrivé tout à
l'heure donc voilà j'ai été marcher un
peu dans izmir et j'ai travaillé et puis
demain
grosjean et le travail en prévision et
puis je dois organiser mon départ vers
donc les zones dragage travail qui sont
plus dans les terres sachant que mais il
faut aussi que j'organise là un peu
manière dont je vais me déplacer me
loger voyage il ya plusieurs solutions
possibles et tout ça je dois le mettre
au clair maintenant voilà c'est comme
tout travail de terrain je pense que
c'est un truc qu'on retrouve chez tous
les chercheurs fin de mois j'espère mais
il ya une partie un peu stressante
ou dragon du jeu c'est un terrain que
j'ai déjà investi que je connais déjà
bien je connais des gens sur place et
cetera mais on sait jamais trop comment
va être reçue si c'est mal perçu ou pas
voilà donc c'est j'ai un peu de stress
par rapport à ça et en même temps je
suis super contente et excitée va de de
retourner sur ce terrain puisque mes
premières données date de 2018 du
printemps 2010 donc ça fait oublier
trois ans j'y suis retourné en 2019 donc
voilà c'est dès 2020 en 2009 en 2010 la
fille donc voilà c'est de donner qu'il
faut que j'actualise j'ai plein de
nouvelles questions et tout donc enfin
et puis le fait de suivre des gens
pendant plusieurs années c'est hyper
intéressant
enfin bref j'ai arrêté de blablater ce
que c'est patrick ont créé ce que je
raconte
je vais essayer de vous montrer en plus
possible à quoi ressemble le quotidien
d'un chercheur quand il fait son travail
de terrain fait en tout cas le mien vous
à voir que c'est un peu particulier
parce que c'est c'est une période en
train en tout cas dans mon cas et ses
modes de travail hyper intense
déjà le fait d'être tout le temps en
mode analyse alors qu'on vit des
situations voilà deux rencontres
d'observation de deux du travail et
serra en plus donc moi c'est pas ma
langue maternelle
donc ça devrait un effort de plus c'est
bon vous allez voir mais en plus ça
donne en tout un travail de deux tenu
d'un carnet de terrain et cetera qu'il
faut vraiment faire avec
enfin voir quelle forme être assidu je
pense parce que c'est des données hyper
précieuse donc voilà je sais pas
pourquoi maintenant je suis là
exactement parce que j'aimerais passer 3
jours 2 à 3 jours sur sûr mais zone d'
enquête pour révolter on va dire une
dizaine à une quinzaine d'entretiens
sachant que le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer que nous sommes de nouveau
confiner le week end
donc voilà les aléas du terrain en temps
de kobe déjà je suis super contente de
pouvoir me rendre la pareille c'est
aussi un peu d'appréhension parce que je
sais que c'est des zones ont clairement
le port du masque et compagnie ne sont
pas vraiment rentré dans les moeurs on
va dire donc voilà enfin bref je front à
voir il ya plein de choses qui doit se
mettre en place
mais voilà j'ai hâte et j'ai hâte de
vous montrer surtout sinon j'espère que
vous appréciez la déco très rococo de ma
chambre d'hôtel
[Musique]
bon
bon je suis de retour à la maison
voilà il ya eu un bref j'ai dû j'ai dû
partir demain terrain avant même d'y a
vraiment arrivé au final tout simplement
parce qu'on vit ça nous échappe à dans
un contexte sanitaire compliqué et que
j'ai eu 1
une nouvelle qui m'a fait douter
concernant mon état et voilà je ne me
voyais pas me déplacer en ayant un doute
en fait il y a une possibilité que je
sois cas contacts on n'est pas sûr mais
voilà sur les conseils du médecin j'ai
préféré rentrer et me mettre à
l'isolément tout simplement
voilà donc bah voilà c'est la vie c'est
comme ça et il était hors de question
que je mette que je prenne un risque
pour les personnes avec qui je travaille
qui sont en plus des personnes qui n'ont
pas forcément accès facilement aux soins
de santé
je le plus juste faire un test et
continue ma vie mais en fait tu vois la
façon dont tu es un peu tous les sons
gloss mais il ya des possibilités que
l'on était soit négatif parce qu'on n'a
pas encore récupérables à vendre f voilà
sur les conseils du médecin
je suis rentré je vais rester isolés
pendant plusieurs jours voila voila
c'est fait jaser bizarre du coup de de
me retrouver là mais bon bah c'est la
vie et puis bah je vais reprendre mon
travail de lecture et d'écriture et le
terrain ne bougera pas et puis on entre
dans la dans la haute saison agricole
aussi donc sur mon terrain donc voilà
c'est c'est encore le temps quoi je pas
du tout pressé enfin voila en gros
pourquoi je voulais me rendre sur le
terrain là j'ai déjà en fait récupéré
pas mal de donner au printemps 2010 8
donc dans le cadre de mes recherches de
master et en ce moment je suis en train
d'écrire un article qui serait ma
première publication universitaire et
cet article se fonde sur donc les
données que j'ai récolté à l'époque et
maintenant que j'ai formulées en fait
mes hypothèses et cetera je voulais déjà
les confirmés et puis réactualisé mes
données vérifier que la situation est
encore là même sur place ou pas voilà à
faire une accusation qui est dans tous
les cas essentiel est en fait je m'étais
fixé une deadline parce que je dois
présenter une première version de mon
article d'ici la fin du mois d'avril
en fait je vais devoir le même le
soutenir en vue sorte devant
universitaires turcs qui avaient une
ponte dans les études migratoires et c
est ce vrai que j'aurais beaucoup aimé
pouvoir
bah voilà présenter quelque chose de
complet de d'actualiser d'être sûr de
moi de mes données de voilà pouvoir
forcément s'aimer questionnaire de
master donc c'est de donner super
intéressante mais il me manque plein de
choses parce que j'avais pas emmener ma
réflexion aussi loin encore et j'avais
pas formulé français plutôt à l'époque
sam était un peu tombé dessus on va dire
les les choses que j'avais remarqué
alors que maintenant que j'ai prise
entre les pensées de l'est
conceptualiser et bien voilà il ya
beaucoup de choses que j'aimerais
approfondir donc bon en fonction de ba
de la suite je verrai si j'ai le temps
de retourner sur le terrain d'ici la fin
du mois d'avril ou pas c'est vrai je
préfère pas me faire de plan sur la
comète et puis tout prendre les choses
telles qu'elles viendront voilà la
priorité c'est de respecter la sécurité
sanitaire de tout le monde et donc je
suis rentré pour cette raison et à
istanbul métal isolement voilà bref les
nouvelles contraintes de travail de
terrain aversion 2021
voilà en tout cas enfin j'avais pas
précisé mais je vais parfaitement bien
je n'ai aucun symptôme je n'ai aucun
problème de santé
voilà à écouter on va continuer ce
épisode de journal de thèse qui aurait
dû vous montrer des paysages un petit
peu différent et un quotidien un peu
différent dans va continuer avec du
travail de bureau à domicile quoi mais
mais bon bah je reste je reste motivé et
surtout ma il va falloir le rédiger cet
article donc bah voila c on me lancer je
pense qu'aussi mine de rien le travail
de terrain que je faisais pour
actualiser m'est donnée c'était quand
même un peu une manière de se dire ouais
mais tant que j'ai pas fais mon terrain
je suis pas trop sûr donc je vais pas
écrire
là j'ai vraiment vu le truc a dit non
allez tu vas écrire ton article tu peux
avoir confiance en toi marine tu as déjà
assez travailler tu connais déjà assez
bien les choses voilà voilà
par la force des choses je vais je vais
l'écrire cet article mais arrêté de me
cacher derrière un mais je ne suis pas
assez c'est sûr il faut plus savoir qui
est un problème très féminin dans la
recherche et ça m'énerve
si nous alors que je suis en train de le
faire pour moi même alors que je le sais
enfin bref voila voila voila je vous
retrouve du coup bas pour la suite de ma
thèse depuis istanbul
[Musique]
du coup je suis à istanbul et je j'ai
repris le travail dès vidéographique
donc je me suis motivé pour publier un
pour rédiger une note de lecture qui si
elle est acceptée pourrait publier sur
le site hi hi alors d'ailleurs bayac
c'est toujours mon pour en parler à yakh
c'est un collectif de jeunes chercheurs
francophones
basé à istanbul et on publie voilà des
articles qui sont à la fois des capsules
de terrain des analyses de hashtag des
dessins commenté dévoila des extraits
d'entretiens des notes de lecture et que
c'était avant tout le tous les à-côtés
de la recherche tout ce qu'on veut pas
publier d'un point de vue qui est
vraiment très institutionnel et en plus
bas voilà on est tous ceux issus de
champs disciplinaires différents
d'institutions différentes
ça nous permet de nous réunir et
d'échanger autour de nos problématiques
très particulières qui sont le fait de
faire un terrain en turquie puisque
c'est notre dénominateur commun à toutes
et tous
donc voilà après la phase plus interne
on va dire c'est qu'on organise des
journées d'étude des ateliers des tables
rondes voilà des désastres enfin au
moment des ateliers ça nous permet
d'échanger par exemple sur un texte que
l'un d'entre nous ou l'une d'entre nous
a écrit voilà donc aiac si vous voulez
suivre nos publications voulaient
retrouver alia qui sur facebook et sur
twitter c'est aiac recherche et puis
surtout sur le site hypothèses dont vous
pouvez mettre aiac hypothèse
dans google et vous avez tomber dessus
voilà c'est ça vous intéresse un peu de
lire de la recherche sans que ce soit
trop impressionnant on rêvait relatif et
bien à yakassé la plateforme pauvres et
autres choses dont je voulais vous
parler c'est que je j'ai réouvert un peu
j'avais envie de réécouter les enfin
d'avoir comme un sons d'ambiance quand
je travaille et j'ai trouvé une vidéo
alors je vois qu'elle a plus de 6
millions de vues donc bref et peut-être
que je veux pas du tout découvrir que ça
mais en fait il ya plein de vidéos sur
youtube qui sont des vidéo d'ambiance
c'est à dire que vous avez une bande son
moi j'aime bien celle de bibliothèque où
il ya un peu la pluie dehors un bruit de
cheminée plus de pages qui se tournent
de stylo qui grattent les pages des gens
qui discutent à voix basse etc
du coup c'est une ambiance sonore qui
dans mon cas mettre vraiment concentrés
en fait c'est assez surprenant je
n'aurais pas pensé parce que par exemple
je suis incapable de travailler en
musique
voilà pour des tâches à l'époque où je
travaillais dans le privé que je faisais
des tâches parfois un peu rébarbatif
c'est vrai que j'aime bien écouter des
gens parler en même temps la bombe
évidemment c'est pas trop possible quand
j'ai dû travailler on va dire
intellectuelle mais justement l'espèce
de bruits d'ambiance qui m'aide à me
concentrer donc bah dites moi si pour
vous c'est pareil parce que je pensais
vraiment pas ça assez suprenants plier
hésitez pas à essayer surtout je me dis
même pour lire un livre
si vous attends ça être facilement des
concentrés ou avoir du mal à fixer votre
attention
voilà bonjour ça super et du coup ce que
je fais c'est que donc je lance la
playlist et je me mets un chrono de 45
minutes sur mon portable que je passe en
ne pas déranger et en fait je me force à
accomplir une tâche que je me suis fixé
à la baisse dans les 45 minutes
évidemment ça peut être un peu moins un
peu plus en fonction mais voilà parce
que moi j'ai remarqué que souvent grâce
au chrono en fait j'ai remarqué ça qu'au
bout de 20 minutes et j'ai envie de
faire une pause
vraiment j'ai ce truc ont besoin minutie
je fini de lire un chapitre que je fini
de rédiger une partie voilà je suis en
mode bon bah ça y est allés chez ma peau
j'en ai marre et tout alors que ça fait
que 20 minutes et je trouve pas ça je
trouve pas ça normal et ni bien donc en
fait j'ai aussi réalisé que mon rythme
intellectuelle me permettrait soit de
continuer donc en fait de fait de savoir
que j'ai un chrono de 45 min à respecter
et bien ça fait que je passe ce petit
moment où j'ai envie de m'arrêter pour
vraiment fermé 45 minutes
du coup je suis fier de moi avec un cinq
minutes j'ai effectué beaucoup plus que
ce que j'aurais fait en même temps du
coup et en plus à la fin de la journée
ça permet de se dire mon mariage j'ai
travaillé tant de temps plus plein de
petites choses que j'ai faites à côté et
ça ça va la mettre un pommeau d'euros je
pense que je vous en parlerai danger
enfin je vais je prépare une vidéo
surtout son organisation de a à z
donc vous en parlerais plus amplement
mais ça fait quelques semaines que je
teste ça et j'étais pas du tout
convaincu par la méthode mais en fait ça
me va bien
bon je montrerai je suis pas non plus
hyper stricte je sais qu'il ya des gens
qui se font je pas eu pour moins d'un
euro par jour avec cinq minutes de pause
entre chaque et tout moi je suis plus
détendu là dessus parce que si je suis
pas d'en montrer de rédaction finale
donc j'ai des tâches différentes
accomplir et tout mais franchement c'est
satisfaisant je suis assez contente de
cette technique
[Musique]